[Music]
this moment
this exact feeling
i wish i could save it for another time
[Music]
according to walter benjamin art before
mechanical reproduction ie photography
had an aura aura is the here and now of
the work of art it's this unique
existence and nothing else that bears
the mark of the history to which the
work has been subject aura is basically
the stuff that the original has that the
reproduction no matter how precise it is
it doesn't have because the original is
tied to a specific time and place but
now that we have the capability to
reproduce things we don't really have to
restrict ourselves to going to the
louvre to see the mona lisa and
according to benjamin this is a very
important distinction and it changes our
relationship to art he goes as far as to
say that the more you replicate a piece
of art the value of that art goes down
and it's not just art objects and places
also have an aura
i'm sitting on this log listening to the
seashell and i feel the aura of the
beach but when i take this home so that
i can have a little piece of the beach
all the time it has less aura
and this
has even less aura aura is attached to
the thing in its purely unmediated form
the beach is there sharing the same
space and time as me today you see lots
of mediations of the beach and that
shows the change in our societal values
we value things for their ability to be
seen by the largest number of people
rather than for their unique existence
and apparently we're accelerating this
loss of aura with our constant desire to
pry an object from its shell
or to be close to something or to be
able to examine it but mind you walter
benjamin wrote this theory in 1936 and
maybe if he was alive today he would
have had a totally different idea like
what about nfts it could be the one and
only copy in this world but you know it
lives in the digital realm so the
concept of its presence and space and
time is kind of totally irrelevant right
but i think the part of this theory that
still is very relevant is how we
interact with objects that we deem to
have an aura when an object is deemed to
have an intrinsic value
we might guard it or hide it away
and we probably spend more time looking
at it
in a more contemplative manner when
people say when you go look at the mona
lisa try to experience the painting and
try to be in its presence
but with reproducible works of art we
tend to look at it less carefully or
speed through it in a less focused
manner it's the same with information
when books were handwritten over time
span of ears they used to hide them from
the public because they were scared that
they were gonna get damaged or burned or
lost and they would literally chain the
books to the desks and what happened is
when you finally got a hold of the book
you would read it and really taken every
word of the book but now with massive
amounts of information everywhere we go
i think it's pretty safe to say that we
take things a little less to heart
umberto echo author and semiotician said
that books in his library had a aura he
had a collection of 50 000 books and he
said as he would roam around his library
on more than one occasion he would
stumble across a book and when he read
it that book magically contained
information that was vital to his
research he was a really strange person
but he called his library an
anti-library and he filled it with books
that he'd never read
he said lots of people have a library to
show off their knowledge to say look at
all these books i read but he uses it as
a research tool and he roams around his
ivory and i think he believes that he is
physically inches away from discovering
new information
and that physical presence of the books
had the power to pull him closer to what
he needed this idea of aura or the loss
of aura in our culture isn't just
happening with art or information but
it's also happening with our built
environments
cities are made up of streets and
streets are characterized by the
building's facades a building's facade
is basically a fancy name well for the
building's face
it expresses the building's character
and it gives you a glimpse of what might
be happening inside
and it's designed to catch people's
attention with our culture's obsession
with images
we experience architecture differently
and our environments are adapting to
satisfy this new way of experiencing
architecture
all the way down to the process of how
we design we tend to focus more on the
shareable moments in our buildings and i
am totally guilty of this architecture
is becoming increasingly rushed and
impatient
leading to issues of experiential
impoverishment our built environments
are void of any sense of mystery or aura
and just like what's happened with art
or information
i think the way we experience the world
is becoming more and more
one-dimensional
and we start to value architecture not
necessarily for its experiential
qualities but for its ability to be
photographed and seen by the largest
number of people
[Music]
venice is probably one of the most
extreme examples of a city whose aura
has been completely and utterly
destroyed thanks to the iconic images
it's become one of the most popular
tourist destinations in the world it
gets something around 20 million
visitors every year
it shows up in movies and books and it's
probably one of the most universally
recognizable locations i'm not gonna lie
when i first visited venice i also have
my preconceptions until i learned this
concept called derive which directly
translates into drifting it's actually a
method devised by the situationist
internationals for navigating through
venice and they define derive as an
unplanned unexpected passage through an
urban landscape where participants stop
their daily routines and allow
themselves to be drawn by the
attractions of the terrain and the
encounters that they find there it's a
place of both connection and
non-connection
a place designed specifically for
getting lost from a totally functional
point of view venice is kind of the
worst place to live
it floods it's full of tourists the
buildings are old it's practically not
accessible for anyone with mobility
issues and you can't drive you can't
bike and in that sense it's the ultimate
anti-city so why is it that so many
venetians who's been driven out of the
city for all of these reasons that i
just mentioned
still dream about one day moving back
there and living there i think it
ultimately has something to do with aura
[Music]
that in the end it's a totally and
completely unique place there's no other
place like it on earth
there's no one else that can replicate
the environment the history
and the city's presence in time and
space not even the most perfect replica
has the aura of venice but as an
architect i still try to look for
patterns in the built environment not
necessarily to replicate but to see if
there's any elements that we can learn
from and as i try to study the build
fabric to understand why it feels so
different from other cities i was able
to distill certain elements or recurring
conditions that helped in creating this
sense of mystery framing
framing is used to hide or highlight
certain elements in this case a narrow
gap between the corners of two buildings
perfectly frame the corner of the
basilica de ferrari dead ends
a key aspect of the reef or drifting is
allowing yourself to be drawn by the
attractions of the terrain and as i
drift through these alleys i kept coming
across these dead ends initially i'd
turn around and backtrack but on
instances when i kept going i found that
it's not a dead end after all and the
corner reveals another alley point of
interest
as i moved through these narrow alleys i
kept feeling a constant pulling like a
push to keep walking
it's obviously the narrowness of the
tunnel but also the light at the end of
the alley or a tunnel that created this
point of interest
compression and release when i followed
the light and reached the end of the
tunnel i would often be pleasantly
surprised to find myself in a
light-filled courtyard or an opening to
a canal or anything that created a
feeling of expansion and as i walk for
hours and hours i felt a constant
compression and release in the landscape
layering layering creates anticipation
depth and a more interesting and
memorable narrative when walking through
space
well all of these conditions did for me
is it created a sense of curiosity that
made me want to discover more and also a
kind of safety i've never
once felt scared or like i was in danger
the city is so so safe because there's
no dangerous corners that sounds like a
really obvious statement but let's say a
typical city with streets and back
alleys the alleys are the leftover
spaces and you know that's where all the
dodgy stuff happens
but in venice everything is an alley and
there's no front and back and everything
is just a continuous labyrinth and
there's doors and windows onto each path
so after walking around for a while and
just being left by my curiosity that's
when i discovered really cool gems lots
of people think venice is a static city
i mean there's been virtually no new
construction in venice for hundreds of
years but actually it has been
transforming at a micro scale since we
can only guess the functions inside the
buildings urge us to discover more
rather than telling us exactly what they
are you see this especially in the
neighborhood of canary
which was once a jewish ghetto these
seemingly benign residential buildings
when you go inside they have synagogues
with ornate lavish details that you can
only discover by exploring further
inside
it's our knowledge the things that we're
sure of that makes the world go wrong
and keeps us from seeing and learning we
have a tendency to put the things that
we know or our knowledge on a pedestal
and treat it as the ideal truth when our
knowledge is often incomplete and
subjective venice only started to reveal
itself to me when i left my preconceived
ideas of venice and kind of allow myself
to be lost and blindly led by my
curiosities and instincts i let my feet
choose the wrong turns and
and i let the light or the textures draw
me into different directions and only
then did i discover a side of venice
that was totally and intimately unique
to me this venice is fleeting you can't
photograph it and you can't take it with
you and it can't be shared this venice
can only be experienced and live as
memory
this venice has an aura that can't be
destroyed
because it can never be replicated and
never fully attained
[Music]
this video is a part of a bigger project
where i try to turn some of the ideas
from my thesis project into a series of
videos the videos together create a hole
so if you found this video interesting
and want to check out the rest i'm going
to leave the playlist right here there's
also so many ideas and concepts in the
thesis i'm not able to capture neatly in
a 10-minute youtube video so if you want
to read the entire thesis project in
detail you can access a digital copy by
clicking the link below in the
description and by becoming a producer
of the channel by becoming a producer
you're supporting me and continuing to
make these thesis videos which is
something i absolutely love
making
but they're a huge amount of work and
they're very expensive to make i decided
not to have any brand sponsorships on
these and if it's backed by a community
that actually wants to see it through
it'll have more meaning that way stay
tuned for the next video which i'm
probably gonna get out in the next two
months please like and share this video
and remember i have a discord server and
a newsletter which are all free to join
i'm going to leave the links to all of
these and the membership tiers in the
description and with that i'll see you
in the next video
my
my